foreign
[Music]
this is StarTalk I'm your host in Neil
deGrasse Tyson you're a personal
astrophysicist and this is going to be a
cosmic queries Edition and I've got a
co-host she's an old timer with us
Marsha belski Marcia welcome back thank
you so much it is always so fun to be
here I learned so much this is my only
postgraduate education oh is that right
okay it's an honor to be back great so
since you do agree to keep coming back
it can't be all that bad for you yes so
today we're going to talk about
asteroids and in recent shows we talked
about the dart Mission the double
asteroid redirect test but that's a
small
microcosm of the total Universe of
asteroids and one of the places where
they do asteroid research is the jet
propulsion Labs so we reached in there
and we pulled out one of the experts
Marina Brunswick
who hails from the jet propulsion
Laboratories in Pasadena California
presumably
they don't only do jet propulsion so
what's what's what is the jet propulsion
Laboratories tell everybody
oh well it's one of NASA's labs and uh
we are specialized in robotic
explorations of the solar system so we
run missions like you know there was
Cassini uh on Saturn and we run Mars
rovers but we also do a lot of science
so a lot of the science work that we do
here are asteroids and to be more
specific we do some very kind of unique
work because we work with planetary
Radars we work with this very large yeah
planetary radar in Mojave desert in
California so
um it is really huge dish like 70 meters
in size
and uh that that is not really by Design
you know planetary radar it's used for
spacecraft communication but when
projects are when missions are not using
it then they give us just they give it
to you know our scientists to observe
asteroids so you piggyback the what was
the original design of that of that
telescope of that yeah it is it is it is
part of deep space Network so NASA NASA
has uh you know you have to communicate
with your spacecraft and so NASA has
these big dishes all around the world it
has it in Australia it has it in Spain
and it has it in Mojave Desert so Marcia
is it just me or does like the phrase
deep space Network just sound like the
coolest thing ever it is so all of this
is blowing my mind like this is so cool
yeah all I know about asteroids is that
people on Twitter were speculating that
one was about to crash into Earth
because they blew up one oh the rocket
ship yeah okay but I don't apparently
Marina told me that's not true so yeah
that's very comforting Twitter generally
is not true what are you serious wait
wait so Marina what do we need radar for
if we have regular telescopes that can
spot asteroids
well so optical telescopes are the ones
that discover asteroids
um and but radar is a follow-up
instrument so um well just to be clear
an optical telescope specializes in
visible light and a radar telescope is
radio waves okay so yeah bouncing so we
are kind of bring your own flashlights
you know optical telescopes uh asteroids
are being you know they reflect some
sunlight you see them as little moving
points on a plane of Sky you measure
where this little moving point is fit
the orbit there you go with radar there
are two things that we do with radar one
is we ping them so we you know bounce
off our little flashlights uh microwaves
off the asteroid which gives us exactly
very precise location where it is uh
with respect to us so line of sight
distance and then we also always say you
know uh in optical telescopes asteroids
look like Speck of Lights
and with radar they become small worlds
and just to be clear that is the
original origin of the word asteroid
when was it Herschel uh who first named
them saw that there was there were these
dots of light moving across the sky and
there were only dots of light just like
regular stars because stars are so far
away they're just dots of light so he
described them as star-like
asteroid Aster Latin for Star Boyd is
like so they're nothing like stars but
to an optical telescope it's just a it's
a star that's moving that's right that's
exactly right that's the origin of the
word asteroid okay so now so now I I
apparently you weren't content just
knowing it was a DOT moving across the
sky were you Marina yeah so uh yeah with
radar so most of the time we are
observing near-earth asteroids and they
are usually say within one tenth of
astronomical unit for from Earth and
they're about at least 700 meters in
size so they're fairly close and fairly
large so an astronomical unit is is the
Earth Sun distance taken as a result as
a new yardstick to measure distance that
is that is a kind of a yardstick for us
but I'm saying so it is we observe
relatively close and as I said they are
relatively uh you know large asteroids
but we are able you know so they know to
be millions of kilometers away from
Earth and we are able to see something
that is six feet in size we can see
surface Boulders it is that level of
detail and and yeah it's like I didn't
even get ready today like don't
know I didn't know you were
photographing me yeah yeah we get to we
get to see a lot of little details
um so so it is really they become and
and you know so every kind of observing
session knows to be like a uh like a
mini space mission because you're flying
you know there's asteroids coming in our
neighborhood and we ping him with radar
and reveal how it looks like we know we
are very interested always how large it
is because you know that is that is one
of the kind of key parameters or yeah
you think okay
well but but wait so I've heard rumors
that that many asteroids might just be
piles of rock traveling together sort of
loosely held with like chewing gum and
and bailing wire sticky putty so so
please please fix what I just said uh
make it right or make it wrong but
that's that's those I heard I heard tell
that that's what the people are saying
the people are saying what Twitter is
saying Twitter is saying it's just made
of gum and rocks up there I guess
Twitter was right this time because
especially you know they are Rebel piles
we think you know anything larger than
about
you know 200 meters is really loosely
held together aggregate of rocks of
various sizes so you know like small
rocks big rocks um a lot of five dust
like regoliths and so and you actually
can see that in space missions I mean if
you if you have seen the images of
asteroid bennu that NASA's osiris-rex
took it's rock on a rock on a rock you
know it's it's all rocks just just piled
up and if you saw images from the latest
dark Mission uh the one that smashed
into the moonlit uh you also saw that
both of the asteroids they looked they
had huge Boulders so very you know and
and basically there's a Loosely uh
Aggregates of rocks loosely held
together by gravity by their own gravity
so even though they're small we think of
small things of having hardly any
gravity but whatever gravity they have
it's enough to so they have some kind of
shape otherwise you expect the rocks to
just drift away right yeah actually
that's a good point that you're making
because so there is something
interesting that happens uh these rocks
when they spin fast about two hours
um very often they end up with a
satellite because basically you the
first two things happen the kind of the
material starts you know the starts kind
of traveling toward the equator
and it starts kind of you know gravity
can't pull it anymore it starts flying
off and then it clumps into a satellite
so that is uh so that is exactly you
know we know wait wait wait Marina I
wanted to I want it to become a ring
around the moonlit that would be so yeah
it'd be cool if our moons could have
rings I've always thought I know well I
mean I want you to work on that and yeah
and get back to us on Monday morning on
this right those are very hard observed
observations those would be very very
hard observations because you know you
would have to kind of really catch it in
action uh you know how how there is a
there is a ring around some uh the
asteroid and then it's clumping into a
moonlit okay so so the clumping happens
you know whoever is the biggest one in
any moment continues to get bigger so
the big ones get bigger and the little
ones get eaten all the little no
actually so the primary the most of the
binaries look we have a large primary
that kind of has a top shape it bulges
at the equator okay it has J2 you would
know what J2 is and then
um why did that sound so insulting you
would know about J2 Neil
yeah it's a gravity it's a gravity
parameter that that things that are
squished it measures things that out of
symmetry yeah you get to see how out of
symmetry it is yeah okay you know he's a
physicist yeah we got this yeah so they
have they have this bulge at the equator
and as I said you have this loose
material that that keeps getting
transferred into orbit and then the
small moonlet forms and so usually the
they're very you have a large primary
and small secondary and we we only found
in the Earth's population only four
equal Mass binaries so something that is
like equal size and they seem to be
different because we double asteroids
basically correct they are actually
they're actually level asteroids wow
well I think we have questions from our
from our fan base a patreon fan base so
we do so Marshall I haven't seen these I
don't think Marina has seen these either
so you're just pulling these out of The
Ether right here yes keeping you on your
toes exactly and now you can't hide the
conspiracy is because they got to reveal
the answers now you know what J2 means
so yeah and now I know now me and the
audience knows J2 but but just to be
clear just to be clear
um
J2 is among various other parameters
that exist mathematically that allow us
to quantify
but how much the the deformities that
are in The Shapes of Things rather it
looks like a football or it looks like
this exactly we can like put a number on
it I can hand that number like through a
text to a fellow scientist and they'll
know exactly what I'm talking about and
then they'll go it does look like a
football
yeah okay I'm going to really be nerdy
joke here that football would have c22
don't don't no there you go there
someone listening is going to appreciate
that they're gonna need that all right
so Marcia let's finally get to some
questions from our patreon fan base okay
let's do some questions
what do you have for us so this first
question is from yanev from Israel yanev
costs cool and it says why do all
asteroids look gray are they really gray
if so why or are they are we always just
using black and white cameras oh I'd
like that Marina we want color here
right so what's what's up with this
what's going on
yeah yeah so they don't um uh no we
don't use definitely black and white uh
cameras there are plenty of spacecraft
with a you know full color cameras but
asteroids are actually quite dark
um they have something so we measure you
know how dark they are and something
there's something called Albedo it is
how much of the sunlight they reflect so
uh most of them don't have all they
reflect maybe at most about 15 to 20
percent of sunlight
um so they indeed are kind of very
various shades of of gray dark gray it
sounds like yeah yeah it's it's very
it's very dark gray I mean if you if you
ever kind of looked at the um you know
some samples of meteors they know to me
quite great except there are certain
types there is one type that is really
like almost like a little marble I I
it's very rare it's instatite it's
called instatite and it looks literally
you just made that up to sell
yes they are beautiful yeah they're
beautiful kind of marble white with a
little kind of great gray specks and uh
they're very pretty so they're they are
there but they're rare they have like
you know like 30 to 60 they reflect
about 30 to 60 percent of sunlight so
there are some of them which are really
bright but they know to be also as a
charcoal you know the ones that have a
lot of carbon they reflect maybe few
percent of light so so yeah they're
mainly they're merely actually actually
pretty pretty dark they don't look like
much like
all right Marshall You Gotta Give us
give me another one keep them coming
okay so this is from Jen uh they say hi
from Michigan I've been hearing about
the Trojan asteroids lately did I hear
correctly that they are in Jupiter's
orbit and how can that be I thought that
part of the definition of a planet was
that it had to clear its orbit oh this
one this one Jen did some homework on
that one
oh yeah yeah
favorite topics back to Pluto everything
people are still not over Pluto
let's get to we'll get to that answer
right when we come back on our first
break from cosmic queries the asteroid
Edition with our guest Marina
so good from the jet propulsion Labs
we'll be right back
we're back StarTalk Cosmic queries
Edition we're talking about asteroids
with my co-host Marcia belski Marcia
welcome back to start talk thank you so
much so glad to be back and you're in a
Comedy Festival coming up in November
November 13th the on Alan Cummings what
does he have to do with this
so Alan [ __ ] owns a Cabaret Bar
um in the evening that's funny because I
saw him on Broadway performing in the
musical Cabaret so maybe somebody saw
that and said this is this has gotta we
gotta keep keep doing that so I have a
solo hour there called marshabelski
Evangelical where I will do my musical
comedy and the like and it's on November
12th at 7 30 p.m at Club coming which is
Alan Cummings Cabaret Bar and it's for
New York Comedy Festival so it should be
really fun and your music your your
musical comedies hilarious what was it
thank you so much my favorite song was
it 100 tampons was that the one yes
that's the NASA song NASA Circle 100
that's all I'm gonna say you got to go
find out the way this woman is coming
from
so we have as our guest our asteroid
expert Marina
uh working at the jet propulsion Labs
could you tell us how you got to where
you are if somebody wants your job or
rather if someone wants a job like yours
what's your background
well as I said I did is amateur
astronomer you know I've been amateur
astronomers since high school and you
know little by little I went I studied
physics but just to be clear Marcia
Marcia when an amateur astronomer is
actually an expert all right you would
never go to an amateur you would never
go to an amateur neurosurgeon or an
amateur
amateur storms are experts in the night
sky and they live nothing better than
showing off their telescope to whoever
will walk by and stop and look through
Okay so we've got amateur astronomy in
the house and then what happened I you
know went to study Physics and I then I
did grad school in physics
then I was a postdoc and at Caltech and
Caltech is and JPL I have very good
connections and there is constant
transfer of people between the two and
so when the time came you know I
interviewed for JPL and I've been here
ever since cool so does your paycheck
say NASA or Caltech it is really Caltech
that's what I was wondering contractors
yeah we are we are contractors
yeah JPS
so we're actually contractors of NASA
APL Applied Physics lab it's Applied
Physics lab back on the East Coast yeah
back on the East Coast that's our you
know that's very very excellent what we
are NASA lab yeah you got it okay so
Marcia uh that question we left off with
which was remind me yes so this was from
Jen from Michigan and they were asking
there are trojan asteroids in Jupiter's
orbit and how can that be because they
thought that part of the definition of a
planet was that it had to clear its
orbit and Pluto is listening to this
right now okay
ears are burning
yeah yeah no that's a that's that's a
very great question yeah uh Trojans are
very interesting population of asteroids
uh they are in a the stability points so
there is actually you know there imagine
this triangle between Jupiter sun and
this Clump that has
um that is basically
objects are able to orbit there without
Jupiter kicking them so there is a clump
of asteroids Trojan asteroids along uh
Jupiter orbit that is in front 60
degrees and then there is another Clump
behind also 60 degrees and that's where
some as I said they're still orbiting
the Sun but Jupiter is never managing to
catch up with them to kick them out
so these are stable these are you know a
gravity stability points where kind of
Jupiter gravity and Sun gravity are at
peace and and you can you can just sit
there and also orbit the Sun and uh it's
very yeah it's it's they're very
interesting because so they basically
collected there right nobody put them
there just asteroids wandering
throughout the solar system found that
to be a safe space for them in a sense
and Jupiter sitting there trying to swat
them away
exactly yeah well actually there is I
think the front groups are front group
of Trojans so the one that's speeds 60
degrees that one is called
Trojans and the one trailing are Greeks
so so that the objects yeah the objects
in the first Clump are uh named after
Trojan Warriors and Trojan heroes from
mythology and the the trailing one is
the Greek camp
and Nessa has actually and Jupiter is
trying to keep the peace there right
between Troy and Jupiter the Roman gods
much later a later God is keeping the
peace yes yeah and this has actually a a
mission called Lucy that is going to
explore objects from both of these camps
from Jupiter Trojans it will first go
through you know it it's it's in such a
it has such a kind of orbit that is
first going to swing through one one
cloud of Trojans and then it's going to
go and explore you know the other one
and and there's some really you know
these these objects are ancient they're
they're really telling us something
about you know how the solar system was
built so so what fraction of Jupiter's
mass is represented in these trapped
asteroids oh tiny that's that's that's I
mean super tiny when you think about it
actually that what is fascinating you
know when you look at the main asteroid
belt in general I mean so we that's
that's the main essay about is between
Mars and Jupiter and there are millions
of objects there actually billions if
you really count the small sizes but if
you were to sum up everything everything
in the main belt if you were to glue
them together together it is less than 1
25th of our moon
and most of that mass is actually in
asteroid in dwarf planet series is about
thousand kilometers across so you can
imagine you know uh if if all that big
mass of main asteroid belt is so tiny
and and Trojans I mean if you were to
sum up old Trojans that's that's that's
really it's even less so so it's really
tight so the idea of clean of clearing
your orbit it just means there's nothing
else big to compete with you it doesn't
mean there isn't debris and other junk
that could be there
as one of the criteria for Planet Hood
yeah well as I said I I definitely have
to go and read up on my uh you know what
is the exact definition but I can tell
you this is a Jen Jen asked this
question yes done for Michigan just just
don't get me started here so here's the
point there are other objects around
where Pluto is orbiting the Sun that
have mass that rival Pluto
cleared its orbit in that sense right
but you can have junk junk so it's about
who's the alpha
okay Pluto's the alpha Pluto is not the
alpha dog but yes Jupiter is totally the
alpha Jupiter is yeah Jupiter completely
dominates the solar system absolutely it
dominates yeah yeah dominates not only
its orbit it's really the right I agree
you know Earth is the size of its storm
you know it's red spot so yeah yeah and
if Jupiter is listening I've always
believed in you and I always thought you
were a planet so don't let the haters
get to you
so now the asteroid belt so one of the
asteroids in there I have one named
after me this I got an asteroid that's
there's one three one two three Tyson
yeah you have it very easily I mean
you're really kind of almost Rhymes one
three one two three yeah it's easy I
don't have to that's not a hard thing to
remember that yeah just for people to
know that asteroid is not my password on
anything I want you to know
yeah I'm not that's stupid
so yeah I mean your asteroid has quite
interesting story well first of all it
was discovered by Legends in in field of
asteroid it was discovered in 1994 by uh
Carolyn Shoemaker and David Levy yes and
they're both asteroid hunting team like
no other yes yes English Majors both of
them
throwing it down yes yes okay yeah yeah
yeah I mean they were I mean this is
this is what this is the power of
amateur astronomy yes um actually they
both went on to get all possible
honorary degrees and Awards in the field
I mean they truly wear Legends in the
field and so so yeah 1994 they
discovered asteroids uh called 1994 Ka
which will later have your name
um and yours is a binary asteroid you
know how come I didn't know that when
did we fight did you find that how did
you how did I not know that in 2015
there was I went looking as I said I I
went to their database yeah we did some
homework okay I know and in 2015
um there was a companion so you have a
primary that is about 11 kilometers in
size so nice size asteroid and then
there is a satellite about four
kilometers in size wow and
um I can tell you that at least 15
percent of main belt asteroids are
binaries and similarly similar amounts
are in in binary or binaries we have a
near Earth population so you know kind
of they have companions last I checked
it was not a near Earth no no no you are
amazing you are your main belt I can I
can also tell you and you can verify
just verify for me Neil needed to verify
that because imagine imagine the bad
press if the Neil Degrasse Tyson
asteroid hits there
that would blow up on Twitter I'm sure
you would never live that down I get
canceled I did rejected oh well I look
at I looked at your orbit and I really
feel like I'm giving you a horoscope
here I do but
um
doesn't that sound great I looked at
your orbit today it sounds invasive in
some ways
that you are um a little bit eccentric
and slightly inclined oh so interesting
so yes so um I don't like being inclined
yes yes you know everybody's in plain
and you're kind of okay yeah you were
kind so inclined it means the orbit is
tipped relative relatively eclectic yeah
playing of the Earth orbit around the
Sun so that is
right and then you have the uh you said
I'm a little bit
um eccentricated not quite a not quite a
perfect circular orbit they're not
perfectly circular orbits but yes it is
um yeah it is it is actually very very
cool object well thank you wait so Neil
did you know that Marina made a video
animation of your asteroid no I didn't
know that yeah oh my God it shows I
think doesn't it show the path of it
over
okay here it shows orbit for the next
year so that you need you know you you
need to know to keep track of your
Asteroids for the following year to keep
track of my real estate yes okay and I I
use their super secret software to
visualize it oh my gosh so this is my
escape plan if I want to escape earth oh
my God figure out how to get there
you got people I got people
my people will talk to your people
I'd love this oh my gosh so that's one
out of like a gazillion asteroids there
and boy the solar system looks like a
busy place
it is a very busy place so there are
millions of objects in the main Bell
possibly billions if you're counting uh
really small sizes but you have a pretty
sizable property there I mean that is a
pretty hefty asteroid and it's a binary
I know so that makes it extra special
how much could he sell it for two years
March is my my real estate agent here
it's got three bathrooms and a kitchen
this housing market people will live
that's where you send your mother-in-law
or father-in-law or whatever yeah
all right cool orbiting a little bit
outside orbit of Mars so inner inner
asteroid melt I'm not it's not hitting
Earth that's all I care about right now
well I don't know maybe a couple of
million years
it takes time you know all the
equivalent movies you have you know the
uh something is a man belt then three
weeks later it is on Earth
because they got to do it within two
hours they got to do it yeah yeah that
process takes usually a very long time
you know it's it's really we're talking
millions of years until the you know
objects from the main belt space
migrating into the near better hope it
crashes into the ocean
well then you have tsunamis
okay that's size 11 kilometers yeah yeah
it doesn't matter that would be
dinosaurs I mean that would be dinosaur
size I mean yeah
you do not want that size uh anywhere
near no matter it's a risk to have an
asteroid named after you that's the
rescue it's just the burden I carry this
is this is what I do
so give me another one see when you slip
another question in before we break
again okay perfect okay this says from
Connor home
um from squim Washington from the
Pacific Northwest hello hello it says hi
on average what percentage of asteroids
have moons is there an upper limit to
how many moons an asteroid can have I
didn't even realize asteroids can have
those wait wait so so let me top that up
and say can because we learned that you
said about 15 or binary so maybe if one
is big and one is small we'll say it's a
moon can a moon have a moon can a moon
have a moon that is that is a very good
question and if you look in uh orbital
mechanics there is no reason not to but
it's not going to be stable for a long
time so so it's probably not going to be
very long-lived but we do have we do
have a triple systems you know in both
main belt and in nearest population they
are rare so you have a you know again
Central object which is the largest and
then you have two moonlets orbiting it
and we found so far
four only four in nearest population so
it's small it's maybe one percent as I
said those are all lower bounds because
you know we can wait wait you're
describing double moons rather than a
moon with a moon yes correct so triple
system so we have we have triple systems
but no we have we have never found you
know a um you know that something that
Moon has a moon that would be very very
well maybe it's just a matter of
definition because
isn't Earth a moon of the sun oh my God
it's all relative
Earth has a moon so it's all relative
yes everything's a move everything's a
moon thank you is it so is the
definition of a moon just anything that
orbits something else
yeah yeah you're oh wow I never actually
say natural satellite we would say that
Earth is a natural satellite of the Sun
and our moon is natural satellite of
Earth so it's kind of I think there were
some efforts to tighten that definition
Marina to correct me if I'm wrong if you
so we Pluto has a moon except the center
of mass of Pluto and its Moon outside
correct so it's it's easier to think of
Pluto as a double a double X Planet a
double a double dwarf planet that you
almost got me to say double Planet there
but I'm not
um as a as a double door I'm taking
notes
then as a main planet and a moon going
around it whereas for Earth our centered
masses within Earth's surface between
the Earth Moon so we can think of we
being a primary and then the moon going
around us so is there any talk about
where the center of mass is and if that
affects the definition
well in the case of asteroids I'm
telling you so
um all of these binaries that I was
seeing it's you're dealing with a really
large primary so Center of mass is
always you know inside pretty much
inside a primary and I told you that we
did find four equal mice but Mass
binaries but kind of we call them that
equal Mass binary binary because they
are they're you know orbiting the Common
Center of mass right right but they're
rare those are very rare objects
all right cool all right Marshall slip
one more in before the break okay one
more before the break this is from Kevin
Browning he says hi from White Deer
Texas I just recently watched Deep
Impact and I was wondering if the idea
of launching nuclear weapons to stop
massive asteroids or comets is just
Hollywood fantasy or has it been
something seriously discussed by
scientists Is it feasible or is it
something that is dated and no longer
taken seriously basically are someone
gonna nuke Neil's asteroid if it starts
coming towards Earth No One's Gonna nuke
my ass
no so two quick things before before we
go to break because I think we'll have
to answer that on the other side so
kudos to Kevin for choosing the Deep
Impact film to reference here and not
Armageddon where Bruce Willis saves the
world I did some analysis of Armageddon
and it violates more known laws of
physics per minute than any other movie
ever made in the history of the universe
so whereas Deep Impact actually had
official advisors for it so kudos to him
there now you you pronounced the word
nuclear nuclear is that what he wrote
I did wait I I think that probably is
just how I said it nuclear what did he
write what did he write he wrote nuclear
the reason why I ask is because George
Bush former governor of Texas correct
nuclear and I was was he just an homage
to his former Governor yeah
okay we'll find out about deep impact
factor fiction when we return on start
talk
asteroid Edition Cosmic queries
we're back start talk Cosmic queries all
about asteroids love it I got Mark
shabelski here my co-host Marcia what's
your social media footprint where can we
find you
cool media um everything is my name at
Marcia belski
m-a-r-c-i-a-b-e-l-s-k-y except for on
Instagram I am at Marsha Skye because
I've had that handle forever
um but yeah find me there I would love
that you know like Neil said I do
musical comedy um and I also recently
wrote a short comedy play called man and
woman so I post all of that information
on there who can find you there okay and
you're from Oklahoma and say nuclear
okay and I'm from Oklahoma and
apparently say nuclear that's which I
didn't even realize I said it wrong I'm
just calling you out just calling you
out and Marina burjovic from jet
propulsion labs are you on social media
actually no I am one of those you know
okay you actually get work done during
the day yes yes I I had an email
and um it's so healthy and do comedy I
don't I like like to think that I
wouldn't be on social media because it I
can just feel it rotting my brain but
look okay I know it's important to very
many people no no but Jeff propulsion
lab has an excellent public website for
people to visit I know I know I know
they have a great educational yes great
educational site and and a lot of good
information and is it
jpl.nasa.gov that is correct you got it
okay so a lot of good a lot of good
people making those websites excellent
so we left off
by we left off with Kevin from White
Deer Texas Kevin Browning who asked a
question about nuclear nuclear nucleus
so a couple of things let me let me tune
that question for you Marina so
other than deflection of an asteroid
which we know was tested with the dart
Mission how realistic would nukes be
burying them into the uh well in that
case there was a comet that they dug
into and uh can you come if you've seen
the film can you comment on other sort
of accurate or badly inaccurate physics
that was in it
well I did see obviously I did see deep
impact and I did see Armageddon it was a
while back so so I think I I forgot a
lot of my complaints
that's it's to maintain yourself yeah we
only remember good stuff
it's a mental health Factor yeah so you
know but to make a kind of long story
short
um I mean yes I mean nuclear devices are
a kind of Last Resort if something is
really big and we don't have much time
to react but in reality we would have
probably decades to prepare and we would
probably go with the kinetic impactor
you know something that Darth Vision
just demonstrated on on datable system
so kinetic impactor it's moving so fast
that the energy of the uh its kinetic
energy is sufficient to create the
explosion that you're interested in yeah
so there are two things there um you
have to just push it you don't want uh
there is a the you know difference
between deflection and disruption
deflection is you just want to push it
disruption is if you hit it too hard and
it goes in pieces and then you have much
bigger mess because all of those pieces
are heading your way big mess so it's a
big mess so if you decide to go with
that kind of you know disruption then
you better give enough energy that all
of them you know clear earth right so
that is that would that you would
probably have to do with the multiple uh
kinetic impactors that is that is not
easy or we need a death star a death
star
that would be like oh well you know just
obliterate it that stars obliterate
planets that's what they do yeah wait
but that's comforting you said that
likely if there was any like major event
that was gonna disrupt Earth with the
technology we have now we'd have decades
to prepare yeah we as I said the first
the first and foremost you have to find
them you know you have to find find them
before they find us that is kind of this
cliche
you know that we've been we've been
repeating but it's so true
um and that's why we find the Sleeping
Bear before this the bear finds you
sleep oh my gosh no pressure we have
these you know NASA's funding uh a lot
of these optical telescopes that are on
every clear night going and looking up
these after these uh after near Earth
asteroids that can potentially endanger
Earth and um you know we still have way
to go okay but there's something you
implied but I want to sort of tease out
here and it's that uh Marcia I think
Marina said that if we find one we'll
have perhaps 10 years because any the
good thing is that anything big enough
to render us extinct is easier to find
right right
so that makes sense well okay here's the
good news here's the good news
um we are really concerned with things
that are larger than one kilometer
because those are the ones that really
have Global consequences the impact of
that and we have found more than 90 of
those objects so we think there are
maybe maybe several dozens that we still
have to find
but there you know some of them are not
easy because they could have exotic
orbits like they can be very inclined
and you know and there can be kind of
you know a lot of times in a bad
geometry so the Earth is on one side and
there behind the Sun and you just kind
of play this hide and seek for a long
time so Marcia those asteroids are
sentient so they know to hide in the
glare yeah they're hiding like the ones
from Jupiter and we're like get out of
there we want to see you
so what would be like worst case
scenario like shortest amount of time we
would have to like prepare
but if something huge was hurtling at us
it's called kiss your ass goodbye
yeah it's it's as I said I it's it's
it's extremely unlikely that that would
happen because as I said we found more
than 90 percent of that uh population we
are very uh concerned about so Global
consequences but we still still have a
lot of work between this smaller
population so we think anything you know
between 140 meters to one kilometer uh
that is that is pretty serious as well
uh we found about 50 of that population
um so we still have a way to so as the
size gets smaller we have less and less
of the total known in our catalogs just
because they're harder to try very very
very much so and and we are you know we
are also very concerned with this
population that is between say 50 meters
and 140 meters it doesn't look much but
you know that is at the level of a city
extremely dangerous and and we we really
know very small uh uh population there
so the kilometer size asteroids are are
enough to disrupt civilization in some
fundamental way yeah right Supply chains
Transportation yeah they basically they
aggregate so much so much dust they
would kick so much dust up in the
atmosphere that you know you would end
up that plants would start having
problems with photosynthesis and then
the whole chain reaction with the you
know with the food with food chains
would collapse but Marcia you know who
would really have the problem anyone was
where it was where it hit that's what
I'm thinking too and if it hit Manhattan
but that's where the real problem is
that that's um do we have enough
telescopes pointed here going back to
Neil's asteroid that was discovered in
1994 you know what else happened in
1994. oh yeah it kind of started right
oh boy do you want to tell what happened
that wasn't the Shoemaker 99. so this
was the first time we ever witnessed a
major Comet slamming into another object
in the solar system and it was a comet
that broke apart from gravity okay and
it was slammed into Jupiter and one
piece after another hit I was and Hubble
Telescope was just freshened a couple of
years earlier and we turned every
ground-based telescope to it in fact I
was at an observatory in Chile and I
took time out of my observing plan to
get data on that Comet and you know
what's cool and see I'm getting all
excited thanks Marsha Marina for sending
me on to this so I so because there was
a comment that broke apart each piece
became its own comment so each piece had
its own tail it was the coolest thing
and yeah it slammed into Jupiter killing
all the dinosaurs on Jupiter I was like
poor Jupiter it doesn't deserve that
yeah and it was discovered it was
discovered by the same people that
discovered your asteroid
they are legends yes I know I know there
It Is Well you were missing you Carolyn
Carolyn Shoemaker and David Levy also
discovered your asteroid and then there
was also Jean Shoemaker Jean Shoemaker
that he was the third they discovered it
from palomarch here
um just in the neighborhood it was like
40 centimeter telescope
um and they discovered a 93 and then in
94 it slammed into Jupiter it was it was
incredible I mean
wow one of the Great Moments and and so
what I wonder is who was looking at our
planet when that same size asteroid hit
Earth and took out the dinosaurs were
they was someone else getting excited
when they saw that there were some alien
civilizations like poor things they did
not have they you know dinosaurs did not
have space program but we do yeah you
know if they had a space program they'd
still be here because they would have
totally deflected that astronaut I mean
this sounds like an amazing Pixar movie
like should we pitch this should we do
the dinosaurs with Dinosaurs with NASA
right yeah and they prevent their own
Big Bang well they said sort of been
done it's sort of been done is this is
down the rabbit hole here but ice age
five
the Animated Series
um I actually have a cameo in that I was
gonna say like how do you know I I
otherwise would not know and I wouldn't
even known it had five five
installations so apparently they
discover these are like Ice Age mammals
they discover that there's an asteroid
headed their way and they want to
deflect it and so I show up inside one
of the creatures heads and a buck weasel
and I'm Neil de Buck weasel and I'm just
in his head I'm in his head telling him
what to think about and so they they so
they deflect the asteroid that's good
for that yeah so the animals have the
deflected the asteroid sentient
conversational smart mammals other than
humans have done this in the past as as
evidenced by this documentary Ice Age
five the well-known documentary yeah
let's keep going so you can get a couple
more in here this is from Dylan I feel
like this kind of leads from what we
were just talking about um it's about a
different movie it says greetings
everyone I was wondering how you guys
felt about the movie don't look up is
that really how would we would react and
what could you slash we do to have a
better outcome I feel like you were kind
of getting into this that the myth of
that movie is how fast it would happen
maybe
um and yeah basically how earlier point
to Marina's notion that we might have 10
years in in Armageddon
it was a texas-sized asteroid I know
that was Within Me reminded me that was
within months of hitting Earth and a
texas-sized asteroid would have been
discovered 200 years ago so and the
government could not keep there's no way
the government can keep it a secret it's
in the freaking sky so you got me
started on Armageddon I told you it
violated more laws of physics per minute
than any other let's leave that yeah
there are a lot of space conspiracies
and I think they are hinged upon the
idea that somehow these things could be
kept it's a secret the government
prevents the whole world from knowing
what's in the sky so so
um I I assume you saw it don't look up
Maria I did not I did not but I I do I
do roughly know I do roughly know the
premise so
um yeah but uh going back to what Marsha
already started saying you know it's
it's uh everybody thinks that there is
this one telescope on Earth that can
observe asteroids and there is one
person that knows how to do asteroid
orbit all that is you know public
information right and actually we have
this kind of clearing uh you know
Clearinghouse for for for data
astronomical data called minor planet
center where everybody in this world
that observes asteroids sends in their
measurements it's immediately
immediately you just pull you know and
there are a ton of amateur astronomers
you know that are running uh software
and fitting orbits and the orbits are
pretty much posted on many sites
including our JPL sites not only the
orbits are posted but we also have this
page called Sentry that is pretty much
doing all analysis of the impacts in the
following hundred years following
hundred years so
um so by the way this guy in a cave who
then has to call information is
information is public
uh and everybody has access to this data
it's it's and we as a scientist would
love to talk so we it's impossible that
we will keep anything of course the
government is not competent enough to
accomplish any such cover-ups that are
displayed in the movies there's no way
exactly right but so one of my most
retweeted Tweets in the past two years
was when I said
uh I watched the uh don't look up this
fictional tale of an asteroid where a
scientist Warren and people reject the
warnings and social media takes it
lightly and and then I said by the time
the movie was done I'm certain it was
not fiction it was a documentary indeed
that was how I thought about it so yeah
it scares the hell out of me even though
it was a little bit comical Marina it
was I've been enough in social media and
interacting with the press and with
people that so much of what I've seen
and felt was pumped up and exaggerated
for the movie but it's all there they
didn't pull that out of nowhere there
was a plausibility to it that that that
left me a little scared
in terms of how we would react to any
sort of global catastrophic event yeah
Marcia I don't want to be the
laughingstock of the Galaxy by being the
only species with enough intellect to
have a space program but with enough
stupidity to not know what to do with it
oh you know we're already there you know
that if they've been watching us with
their telescopes they're like these
idiots don't say that I don't want to
hear that well you know we have um every
two years we have this planetary defense
conference
um we're actually
um you have experts from you know from
from from scientists to Engineers to you
know space mission planners to to even
kind of politicians government officials
uh even United Nations everybody gathers
in one spot and discusses hypothetical
scenario of what would we do and there
is always carefully thought scenario of
you know what we know something you know
something is coming our way and what we
know at certain time and then we have
this what do you do Marcia read the
report it ends with kiss your ass
goodbye
a lot of times you see this you know so
we are kind of I'm I'm only going to
contribute there from okay can radar see
it or not and what can we do that's
you're a piece of that puzzle right yeah
but but you know there are people that
are negotiating you know they're
politicians that are going like okay who
is sending what uh you know who is
sending reconnaissance mission uh Every
space-faring Nation will contribute this
and so there you have right if an
asteroid is headed for the Indian Ocean
and we have technology that could help
it who pays for that mission right right
and there's even better one if you want
to deflect it
then say it is going to impact country a
but if you want to deflect and save
everybody it is going to the corridor
impact Corridor will have to pass over
country c d and e right in order to Move
It Off the Earth and if you don't fully
actually they really do exactly you have
other targets yeah the asteroid is
that's probably what would end up
happening they'd be like oh let's just
send it to this country like yeah well
those are interesting questions and
those are interesting questions but
that's I mean that's right many people
that's many people are working on this
because you know we we need to have we
need to have protocols in place and and
um and so this is important well I'm
delighted that you're on the front lines
there Marina this is this is we got good
people doing good stuff trying to save
save the species I feel like the
difference between that and the global
warming though is like there's no
Financial incentives for companies to
allow an asteroid to hit us you know
what I mean I feel like we'd get at our
our butts together that is so
encouraging
I I don't I don't I don't know myself
but think of all the things we do do
that reduce our life expectancy I know
every day so but if I if I if I may add
I think that in recent polls actually I
think that public is very much aware of
um you know the the
um the need for for us to uh find all
the potentially hazardous asteroids so
so I think I think that the public is
that we have kind of public in our
corner with respect to yeah go look at
it go look at the movie don't look up
and you will I will reverse that comment
it is too believable the way that people
reacts in that movie yeah guys we gotta
we gotta land this ship uh so anyhow uh
this has been great informative and
thank you Marcia for sharing your your
joy and comedic outlooks with us and
Marina it was Delight to have you on our
Rolodex and asteroids are always a fun
thing uh you may know Rick Benzel I went
to a graduate school with him and yes of
course we were in the same uh graduating
class and he's a big asteroid guy as
well so I've had some I've had some sort
of osmotic uh asteroid relationships uh
in the past because of that yeah Rick
Rick is a legend in the field yeah you
got it okay guys we're going to call it
quits there thank you for being on Star
Talk uh this has been a stark talk
Cosmic query's Edition asteroids Neil
deGrasse Tyson here as always bidding
you to keep looking
[Music]